ever wondered about the deepest secret  desire of scp-106  the old man who dragged unsuspecting  victims into his hellish pocket  dimension foundation researchers snapped  a picture of scp-106 as he emerged from  a wall using scp-978 the desire camera  this was the result  scp-106 roaming a wheat field appears to  be approaching an old farmhouse while a  woman appearing to be in her mid-60s  welcomes 106.  scp-106's origins are uncertain but it  has always seemed clear that he desired  fear and violence over all else this  photograph tells a different story one  of a man who wants comfort love and a  home of his own it's a fascinating look  into the innermost desires of someone  that seems like a simple monster sadly  he will never have the home he yearns  for condemned to hunt forever and  destroy everything he touches